this week's videos are sponsored by
expressvpn more on them after the
reaction people citizens of the reject
Nation it is time for Monarch episode
thress today John are you excited God
yes oh man I'm Ill with uh excitement
that's insa we got to watch the episode
gu leave a like on this video
SM something I don't know m to the
Subscribe but can't think of anything
clever thank you to prep for helping us
edit down these highlights also thank
you to everyone who's been joining us at
our patreon page for this show full l
through at and watch long where you SN
it with your own copy of Monarch for
super sexual reject cover several things
over there exclusively with highlights
and watch Longs included all righty guys
let's get to
it what's it going to be wait a minute
we don't have a minute you don't want to
find out if your own father's alive or
dead that's your business but I do want
to find
out we start or his Trail ended they
searched for his plane for weeks that's
hundreds of square miles of you know
Alaska snow and ice now this is a
Milwaukee which means an entirely
different pruning process and this is a
Japanese man we just call him a man here
they're on to us get to the
van I'll drive you what interesting
smash to Subs there press the button
button
yes
h Go Jack Burton drive that truck watch
out watch out watch
[Music]
out oh
boy oh that was a great shot truly
throwing down for some car stunts in
this
show are you insane you never drove with
your grandmother hang on and he was in
love with her yeah it's a nice call back
to episode
two oh my God you're destroying all of
Japan yes just drive it right through
all of Tokyo bigger Menace than the
monsters
themselves I'm a better actor than my
son wow what a transition shot they do
look a lot alike nice Saving Private
Shaw they've got to figure out a way
where they can interact with each other
if you two want to keep this our private
little Monster hunting club then fine we
pull the request if you want make a
difference want to do some some serious
science and we need backing damn these
Russel are good actors what kind of
difference are you going to
make welcome to Monarch General oh
Chris hll who' have thought you'd partly
escort Duty into your first command
these Eggheads are already starting to
grow on you sure it's a bit like hurting
cats sir if cats had Geer counters and
thought they were smarter than you
Egghead wants his bookie W Dr M William
Miranda congratulations on your
promotion General well thank you Miss of
course and it's doctor some respect on
my degrees I believe you have something
to show us doctor oh my God he just
called her doctor without incident oh he
a tumor slowly growing in clearly got an
ulterior motive and is a
villain tell me this is some kind of
fossil that would be a reasonable guess
but we took this impression in a muddy
field in Indonesia holy
this is going to give me nightmares this
and this woman doctor nothing a lot of
Firsts today we had a way to lure it out
of hiding all we need is 150 lb of
uranium and let me explain that sir it's
as much as we dropped on Japan hey a
creature like this as big as this is an
existential threat to Global Security
and only Americans can stop it that's
what we do can you imagine if this came
out before any the Godzilla movies I'd
be pretty
excited say what it what is this
building too aside from the inevitable
if it wasn't for you neither of us would
be here that is not a theory that's a
fact so you are saying that there is a
place for gun toting the Ander
thals if we hide who we are and what
we're trying to do then what's the point
of doing it at all they're not trying to
hide it's about easing in yeah you got
to prepare people for like I'm a woman
and and I went to a lot of school I know
medical thing yeah and just general
knowledge of Science and the humanity
nurse no no no uhuh not that kind of
doctor not that kind of doctor no the
nurse not a doctor yeah I am simply an
expert in a field of
expertise Billy kept these journals
scribbl down every crazy thing he came
across till his pencils were nothing but
Nubs I'd be so curious to know how Wyatt
and Kurt worked this role together
something thing in here Hoshi didn't
want Monarch to know about and my gut
says we find it before they do we find
him but may built something to read them
but it's back at her place I actually I
digitized him already what all right
Egghead need you to look in there for
anything about Alaska why does he look
so upset he just feels betrayed when was
Monarch founded uh late 40s thereabouts
who didn't that make you like 90 years
old what can I say good jeans no he's
hiding something Je spent out outside of
normal SpaceTime did our dad really work
for them it is your family business you
got to warn people try to stop it hey
that's exactly what we were trying to do
but you were there you saw it you really
think anything on Earth could have
stopped it then he threw his life away
for nothing oh they could have been
mentally
[Music]
prepared oh they're on a boat that makes
sense I was like why why would there be
such a gridlock right
now bikini
buttom what the
hell
who oh no whoa I told you we couldn't
trust that hey hold on let me handle
this let me just let me handle this what
brief did he give them I mean they're
treating like it's an enemy Must Destroy
This appears to be going in a direction
we didn't discuss we discussed you need
a large quantity of uranium not in bomb
form sir should have been more specific
you could have told us that's not how
top secret nuclear tests work son God
damn it asking for as a chance to assess
what we're dealing with we don't even
know what these things are they're an
existential threat to Global Security
you did say all the wrong things this is
not what they had in mind but it's
become bigger than all of us you ask for
the support of the United States Army
this is it get used to it we know the
the weapons are kind of useless but can
you really blame the arm like I
don't being told this giant creatures
here you I need to illuminated just lead
with your gun you don't need to stick
your neck off for us any longer this is
my fault you cost me my business and my
home my life everything I've built who I
am damn but until we sort out your mess
and I get back what you cost me you do
not get to tell me what I need you're
the real monster man the Mello drama's
the monster
we get one eager Bieber Border guard who
finds these ass and it's game over
immediately so we need to get rid of
these just dump him over why do I have
to do everything you say and why are we
going to Korea my father disappeared in
Alaska I out of Japan didn't I under
this ship no passport a monarch in site
that we know of you did a lot off camera
yes you did you two want to start
calling the shots you got every right so
once we get there where to Alaska like I
said yeah man you don't know what you're
doing I want to call the shots I just
wanted to break you out yeah but I
didn't want your actual
[Laughter]
guidance okay where's your friend just
trust me okay I hope it's a K-pop Cameo
I think we're supposed to be in line
number
two did you want to sweet talk the
lady at the window I got my sister's uh
adopted grandkids with me right so we're
we're on that ship and I told them uh
for safekeeping we got to put everything
in one backpack backpack right so anyway
look jeez I never been to North Korea
Swift no he was speaking in code yeah
somebody else heard well then you're
even dumber than you
look
hey my
[Music]
brother you look younger every time you
look good you look younger
oh ye a little faith come
on welcome to Japan ma'am I was supposed
to be moving my daughter into her
college dorm room this weekend but now
my ex-husband is celebrating this
Milestone with her because Lee Shaw has
decided it's no longer Avail himself of
his generous retirement package I know
so much about her she's poised
successful businesswoman has a troubling
marriage and invested in her there no
get done that plane is
being refueled and we'll be ready to
leave in 30 minutes you'll both Bey on
it Bill Rand is f 6-year-old field notes
and crackpot theories are not going to
help us avert another G yeah Lee Shaw
seems to think otherwise oh if you
really believe they were so important
why not bring it to Dr sarawa
[Applause]
or finally sh's in South Korea official
recognition AI plag him and the others
he's so excited you on that plane in 30
you get a tactical team and get on
Shaw's ass whatever you need I need my
partner yeah loyalty she's really
protecting him loyalty ready for
Meed we're going all the way to Alaska
in that don't think of it as old think
of it as vintage think of it as a sturdy
piece of engineering from an older time
when was made to last hopefully
maybe who
knows they already figured out a way how
to lure seeing the creature already
right it's a theory it's a strong Theory
clearly they like the
radiation oo what do we got attention
attention sonar cont attention
monster we are the US government if
you're out there flap your wings one
time nicely done oh yeah goira it's like
the actual Godzilla movie no test they
are trying to kill it shim we call him
go what the hell does that thing need
protection
from
us and the we do oh my God it is
not bad wow how have we never seen this
thing before if they go through with
this how will we ever know this is wrong
stop the military Shaw if we can't learn
everything we can about the enemy you
wait to see what the enemy is going to
do you've already lost my bad
wow nice oh my God that water
sale look at the Mist on
him that's a great shot let go a great
shot legitimate the hell did he needed
to prove in Kong Skull Island yeah
seriously he's going to wipe out this
whole unit probably I don't
know
8 oh boy oh boy oh boy oh
boy it's
over no dude it ain't going to do
don't
worry guys wow what a solid throwback to
the
original
Godzilla's just going to be standing
there with his arms folded really what
the
that's Billy's handwriting there
yeah these are geoc coordinates from all
over the world everything on the list is
checked off except for this one when I
put it into the map it's in
Alaska if we knew where your father's
airplane was heading when it disappeared
I I could pinpoint this it was flight 74
something filed a flat plan from noome
to Barrow numbers data time to Cowboy Up
Doo we got a new destination I got it
Outback Steakhouse he was headed to
Barrow that's not where he was going he
was going for cigarettes and never came
back their first weapon was strong
enough to make Godzilla go away for a
little bit I gu I don't know unless
Godzilla was just like ah I'm not
dealing with this just swam away General
called me in to discuss our funding so I
gave him a proposal string a monarch
Outpost extra staff monitoring equipment
the works he rejected it gave us more
gave us a bigger budget yeah said we
didn't ask for enough they are giving us
a blank check to find out if there are
more of those out there oh that's a
simple question what if the next one
doesn't pop up in the middle of the
Pacific what if it's near New York or
Washington saying that you want to go
public with the details of a classified
hbomb explosion yes why not because they
electrocuted the rosenbergs this is a
good World building this is really a
World building yeah does the general
need to know everything I'm sorry are
you suggesting that I lie to my Superior
officer no but a lie and a secret are
two different
things what where he got it
from this is why I have affairs cuz a
lie and a secret are two different
things thank you
Lea use that one that you will tell me
everything that I
need to know are you okay with that are
you I'm fine with
it it's my opinion matters n Monarch was
supposed to be something beautiful
bright promising stri away from Shaw
where are we us we come to Papa soon
damn I don't know what I'm more afraid
of though we don't find dad or we do
feels like a punch in the gut either way
and I don't know how many more I can
take let me tell you a secret not a
lie you don't appreciate your life so
much until you're afraid to lose it not
so much when you see other people lose
theirs I saw many people die you get out
of the bay each morning you roll the
dice terrible things may happen true and
never have a chance to tell your papa to
go screw
himself
dude I like that guy I do wish I cared
more about the main two leads this
everything else is really engrossing
interesting
bucking why is he flying is the fast
pilot I know when you're flying by seat
of the
pin put it right up here where I can see
it balance clever old school
leveler oh my God stop
[Music]
Emma
o boy this is going to be rough guys
hang on sh what's that down there
hit my pants no time to think about
it here we
go hell of a job co-
pilot you guys make a hell of a team I
mean that's his daughter it's true I
don't know whose daughter is who Kurt
Russell is the
daughter oh no Kurt Russell's Got to Be
Blood related one of them yeah 747
what
got damn no did not have carousal behind
the
wheel
a that's not
him it's not
[Music]
him seat belts
unbuckled maybe he got thrown free I'll
be monke his naked uncle has he got Camp
do you think anyone's
there oh my God he's going to see us to
kids and be like oh sh
i' never meant for you two to meet
each other this was the place that
strategically you should be least likely
to find me in ever I faked my death cuz
I didn't want to deal with this awkward
finding out about each
other it's like he wanted to land right
here if everyone died in the crash who
set all his Gear Up Poltergeist
researchers
I know that handwriting it's
Japanese me
too whose handwriting is it whoa it's
their mom's he
survived a oh that's a nice
moment yeah been waiting to hug my hot
sister this hold just wait for the right
[Music]
excuse oh oh hatch it's going to
explode kill them
all giant
[Music]
grenade just made it look like or
something else came after they landed
and ripped it apart some kind of M snow
where you going
now nice that's terrifying oh is it a
Yeti PL you come quick move wait how
does he know it's going to like awaken
right
now all right
all oh
wow look at that thing
damn come on my dude this seems like
being in the plane is the worst thing to
be in yeah wo nice like ice vacuum or is
it
like should have got it in the
plane what a
face it's all
right old man shs been able to figure
his way out of every situation uhhuh I'm
sure he'll figure it out oh yeah very
start of the next episode he'll have
like a special whistle or something that
like makes K incapacitated for a
minute jump back into action all right
all
right damn you know with the dad in
hiding yes especially when he doesn't
want to be like caught by a monarch one
of the best things he can probably do is
find ways of securing his location and
hiding keeping it secret but not lying
about it yeah totally totally but what
would the best way to be to to what
would the best way be to I'll show you
right now I'll show you I'll show you
I'll show you naturally naturally to
show you yeah walk me through this yeah
natural show explain it to me I'll
repeat all this you be the camera and
I'll be sure just look at this through
my eyes and naturally show you big
thanks to expressvpn for sponsoring this
video a real game changer I've been
using for years that's right years so
whenever they want to work with us it's
an instant yes you've likely heard about
expressvpn for online privacy and
security but there's more to it than
that however there was a very real
incident recently with Spectrum sheding
down my internet and contacting me due
to a suspecting hacking attempt and
funny enough I realized I hadn't
actually activated my expressvpn on my
new laptop that I got a couple of months
ago so I was paying the consequences
having faced a serious hacking issue on
YouTube a couple years ago that made
expressvpn my goto for both security and
freedom I mean it and yes what you've
heard is true believe me this channel
knows you can use Express PPN to watch
movies and shows on Netflix that are not
available in your country this means
accessing a vast rate of content of over
a 100 countries like a global Cinema ear
finger tips it's super easy open
expressvpn switch locations refresh the
browser and there you have it whether
it's kramas on South Korean Netflix Hulu
BBC I player YouTube or more expressvpn
has you covered and it's incredibly fast
ensuring no buffering or lack for smooth
HD streaming versatile to working on not
just computers but phones media consoles
Smart TVs and more this means you can
enjoy your favorite shows at any wear
any screen protect and elevate your
internet experience so if you want to
get access to hundreds of new shows use
my link expressvpn.com reex and you can
get an extra 3 months of expressvpn for
free that's
expressvpn.com reex so head to
expressvpn.com reject to learn more
thank you again wow that was informative
that was very inform very informative I
have a little bit of a headache but it's
good John did you love it I I liked this
episode quite a bit I did you didn't say
you loved it and I really really really
liked it wow you're not quite at the
love I'm I'm still inching towards love
but I really like it I like that's my
favorite one is yes out of the three
we've seen so far that's my favorite one
sure it's the most sort of like
propulsive and it's got a really kind of
you know the I don't know you're moving
and you've got you know a couple really
good Kaiju touchstones on both timelines
I feel like we're actually unpacking new
okay whereas before even if it is
just sort of flushing out and
Monarch understanding how Monarch came
to be with its uh corruption is a really
cool angle to me of like oh this
actually really did start off as a uh
wondrous Prospect something truly just
interested in learning about these
creatures yeah they're all Oppenheimer
they
are like what horrible horrible door
have we open now we have a clear B
Innovation yeah this is not what we
meant by this yeah yeah no that I I
really like how it seems to Riff on
elements of of of history in the way how
to my understanding the original
Godzilla was a metaphor for threat of
nuclear war am I correct about that yeah
all I think about our big monsters
punching each other the traumas not the
deep and the fallouts ofar war blah
blah blah real life hisorical at put a
guy in a costume and blow up fake build
smash the buildings with your funny
little screams rubber suits rubber suits
yeah yeah my bad what did I say oh I
don't know some about history
and Trauma and you know you got very you
really corrected me on something like R
rubber Greg Greg Greg rub Greg rubber
suits Greg rubber suits rubber suits
Greg guys guys in suits what the first
movie is a real metaphor
about
guys take off the suits you'll be less
angry um but no I mean like the the way
they were showing really
showcasing how the three of them you
know young John
Goodman young Kurt Russell and and
Grandma of Dr and Dr Grandma who just
gets to be the definitive version of her
character because we haven't seen her in
future do Dr woman uh Dr woman what say
you what are your feminine instincts
telling you this time every scene is
it's a doctor a woman doctor whoa what I
hope they bring it every episode yeah
guys it's pet we're we're we're past
World War II now women have had jobs
it's okay so the but that like
everything on the beach and everything
that was like hearkening back to like
while while you do get a little bit of
like Nostalgia homage um um um
emotionality just that entire sequence
yeah I mean it's like it's always cool
to see Godzilla don't that's really cool
and I love the visual too with seeing
through the um yeah through the old
camera through the old camera like wow
that feels so vintage to use their words
uh but it was a great aesthetic touch
and the this show does deal a lot with
duplicitousness and dichotomy and then
seeing that within Monarch itself
of like they did really didn't want to
attack Godzilla they really wanted to
understand and then you're and then
seeing I like I like when they're
cutting back and forth
between I'm I'm I find myself now super
interested and compelled by the cutting
back and forth seeing how Shaw was the
one who went to the Army and approached
them like he was just on some escort
Mission with this doctor and now he's
like open up the door for this secret
Camp of of government and you know they
were like yeah you'll get unlimited
funding we're going to really help you
out and then he cut to the Future and
he's just like we got to keep him in
prison and we're taking control of the
entire thing you know like it's that it
feels like it was really riffing on
something that feels real world yeah and
and the whole time I've been kind of
watching the show going like what the
hell are they expanding upon or showing
me that is really all that different
than what we already know and they've
really I feel like this episode truly
hit the mark and maybe it hit hit it for
people earlier already for me this
really hit the mark on Monarch being
something I really want to one pack yeah
you know that's probably my favorite
aspect and prior to this I didn't really
get that sense I'm like I always feel
like monarch is always being treated
like they're kind of corrupt and then
you need them and yeah because who else
is going to deal with this who else is
equipped yeah and this one really um
gave us a different angle and there's
mystery with like the first time they
actually discover goir which goes back
to when
uh sir zawa does talk about that in the
in the 2014 Godzilla movie you know so
they we got that filled in which is
really cool to really get that entire
thing fleshed out um and should have
said in the middle of the
reaction I'm like well no I know
I just
waited it's okay it's okay you got to be
you got to say everything but don't talk
don't talk too much don't talk too much
but get all the right things to say in
the
reaction
so nothing you know we should just start
pausing wrecking the watchalong
experience and then just like making
sure we get each reference down before
we move on with the show so yeah
bringing that in and and then yeah
uncovering under MOS as well
yeah um my main issue is I really just
don't give a about the two kids
like they're they're the way they're
portrayed is the most Baseline flat to
me it is is
is so Baseline and like I I really like
the moment where they did hug yeah that
was nice they both finally have a reason
to connect over something you get a
sense a little bit more sense of depth
of not willing to be vulnerable because
it's easier to kind of take out this
anger and pain on each other than it is
to deal with the fact that their dad is
dead and did something horrible so I get
the subtext I do it's there it's very
it's very obvious but but the way it's
done the way they go about it is and
it's and that it's hampering of
exposition it just kind of feels
repetitive a little monotonous uh I'm
just not the biggest fan of it and the
performances are fine they're fine
performances they are I'm not going to
see and be like they're bad performances
it but they're not really doing
something to they're not strong enough
though to elevate it Beyond its flatly
written material yeah if I was an actor
I would be hungry for more material to
sink my teeth into as those characters
in particular yeah yeah yeah cuz we see
a lot of this these are archetypical
Beats and so especially when you're in a
position where yeah the script doesn't
seem seems least concerned about
spending time writing that story I I do
feel for the actors in that position
because you're in a position where it's
going to kind
of I don't know you're in danger of
Fading Into know a a long standing Trope
rather than your performance actually
being accentuated by the material the
question about is the dad alive and
what's the dad really up to is just
Lightyear is more interesting than the
actual
kids like the actual just question about
it is so much more interesting than than
the kids even their response too I'm
just like I just want to know what's
going on with the dad and I'm not super
interested like and I think the show
itself is not that interested in them
like the the writing they put around the
grandma who is is great Dr woman she
she's great her performance is great I I
really love her yeah um and then yeah
with the Shaws like so much of that is
very
compelling um so for the most part I
really it's it's all that stuff where
the writing of the characters is the
most intriguing it's them and and I like
ciry Clemens is I think K Clems is a
really good actress but even with her
with the there there kind of seems like
I I feel like some something in the
writer's room I feel a note it might not
be true it just feels this way to me of
we need to provide something to make
them more interest we need like drama
around them to make them more
interesting you could feel like them
like throwing in some note to try to
include so it just reads his kind of
melod drama that bogs it down a little
bit then act actually feels like drama I
find really I personally find really
interesting you know yeah it feels like
somebody mandated these three characters
in the show is like is including them
out of spite and is only concerned with
doing the bare minimum to have them
there yeah which is kind of funny to me
because again this is a show that is
steeped in this lore and is building
this world out but that is you know
having to rely more on its human
elements because they cannot do a money
sequence you know constantly um and yeah
it's it's funny to me because yeah I
enjoyed the immediacy of this episode
and how much this is moving things
forward I'm much more compelled by the
characters combined with the story in
the past this episode was was fun for
the present sequences just because you
know you're on a a ship and then you're
on a plane and we see a new Kaiju and
there's some fun to be had there
although I do and and not to spend too
much time like you know hypothesizing or
rewriting but part of me thinks that
they could have accentuated this whole
plotline with the the two you know half
siblings a lot more if they had utilized
a bit of that GTH Edwards like soaking
in the environment Vibe where they're on
a big you know World spanning Travel
basically and so I feel like we could
have made that feel like experiential in
a way where without even having to like
write extra drama for them we could just
kind of be along for the journey and
bonding with them that way and have like
a few little moment like every time we
come back to those couple of characters
it just feels the most like oh I'm
watching a show with like here's beats
that we got to do whereas I can get more
lost in a lot of the other stuff so it's
like yeah I feel for the actors cuz I I
keep wanting them to you know be able to
I don't know like this got to be a big
opportunity for them and certainly you
know it's it's a good you know calling
card but uh yeah and the and the Bummer
too is that they're and I don't I really
don't know what the general consensus is
on the on them as the main characters
yeah cuz you essentially got two sets of
main characters you got the people in
the past you got the people in the
present yeah and then Shaw is kind of
like the connecting thread between the
two main characters two main sets of
characters right yeah and it's and in
the present we got two Asian leads uh
which I think is really cool to get
especially when you have like the
adaptation of Godzilla Godzilla movies
to get two Asian finally to get like as
like the two Asian leads it's not like
just Ken Watanabe as a co-star lead you
know yeah not not coming in to also fill
something of a Trope character yeah yeah
I I think that's that's really cool so I
I I am wishing that they they they were
given something better here it's weird
that that um kento's mom is the still
the most distinct flavor to me of that
whole story a th% I'm right there with
you cuz yeah she's she is given these
like regular human you know bit lines
but like everything about that feels
like a person and feels like they put a
character on it whereas whereas I feel
like I'm I'm kind of just watching like
two protagonists capital P yeah yeah and
I feel like I don't really have fa Faith
the show is really going to change this
op because this has kind of been an
ongoing opinion for us and I feel like
we can just be very repetitive here so
perhaps if it just carries on we'll just
be like they're still doing the thing we
don't really like whatever but if they
but if we if they didn't doing something
that we really like about it then all
right we'll talk about that because
this episode did ultimately provide me
with a lot of things I really did like
aesthetically really cool I do love the
fact that they Embrace these locations
some stuff is a little bit silly when
you just throw your brain out the window
and you're just like oh it I guess
I got on this fairy
um
Sur I was able to get us on like the
most inefficient form of
travel well even though we have a a
truck here we we took that clearly has a
very identifiable license PL yeah yeah
and we've been under hyper surveillance
up to this point that I'm pretty sure
has reached Beyond The Compound we were
only tractor they gave me was apparently
this this ankle bracelet not some weird
like track room my blood or some
yeah some bug some bugo yeah as
Hightech as this Monarch organization is
and as much surveillance as they have on
me it's okay I got it one step ahead the
government passport situation like all
that stuff this is this is really um spy
heighten that is filled in the blank by
he's done a lot of in between that
we just don't know about but it's fun
and Kurt and Kurt Russell is his
Charisma and charm and his the way he
uses the way he does his line reading
the way he uses dialogue really brings a
lot off the there's a reason why Kurt
Russell is is the legend that he is cuz
he's no he's just known to like he's got
a away with dialogue that that makes
you're like ah it I'm on board you
Kurt Russell um so he and he's such a
delight and I really feel like he bring
he does bring a lot to this role and it
is kind of fun watching because I think
Wyatt Russell's a really good actor yeah
he's one of the best like nepotism you
look like just like your dad kids
a good act and it's kind of like wow
what a daunting thing to be in the same
show as your dad because like your dad
is a whole other caliber of talent and
you're like you're like really freaking
good like you're like Wyatt Russell is a
great I still remember watching that
Black Mirror episode not know oh yeah
not knowing who that that was the son of
Kurt Russell and being like this is a
great actor who is this and then finding
out that oh my God that's Kurt Russell's
son yeah and I had no idea that was Kurt
Russell so like I I formed that opinion
prior to knowing um but it is just fun
watching the roles just feel like one is
just so much significantly more
charismatic but it's it but at the same
time like what Wyatt Russell is doing
that's why I would be curious to know
what the homework is for both of them
because where Shaw is at at the point in
time where Wyatt Russell's at that's
what's required for that performance
yeah like like there is a little bit
more of a Carefree experience and same
time a lot more wounds have been
inflicted on a guy for where for where
Kurt Russell's at where he's just like
this I'm going to play by my own
rules a little bit you know whereas why
Russell was still up and coming and had
to be obedient to the Army at all costs
and everything you know so it is fun
watching the dueling roles there of the
same character and um and uh I do like
the kaju stuff I like the themes of
again of of of human history
that feels like allegorical to real life
to the point where oh when you're
watching the way this portrayed and then
you're seeing the traumatic events of
what today is like with the Godzilla
incidents and the M from the 2014 movie
you're going oh maybe there was a path
where they may have been able to pre
prevent some of this or help prepare
Humanity for it if they didn't just make
that one mistake of we got to just shoot
this thing yeah you know like was there
a path where they could have where we
could have almost like eased each other
into coexistence yeah in some greater
way than just an immediate attack to to
leave that first impression yeah yeah so
there's a lot I really liked about this
I'm really into it when we're watching
it yeah no I too and I'm rooting for it
to continue on and I'm like I'm here for
the mystery and I'm excited to find
stuff like yeah it's it has those those
bits that we have you know well Trot in
in terms of how it could be better and
more gripping dramatically speaking but
shot great too was it oh shot yeah yeah
it no it totally is and and it's one of
those things where it does at least
again when they are going big scale like
look really nice like when you're going
up the back plates on Godzilla and that
whole thing where it comes out of the
water and the Mist is coming out like it
looks really beautiful and yeah like I
am enjoying the spirit and and I think
the way that they do the the especially
the way that they handle being in the'
50s it feels kind of I'm able to just
kind of slip into it and not
be I don't know that like it's nicely
heed to the point where it's not too
stylized and crazy it's not I don't know
it just feels kind of natural it doesn't
feel as much like oh this is a you know
I don't know what I'm trying to say like
the sometimes you can feel the facade
especially when you're cutting back and
forth and especially on like a TV format
like it doesn't feel like they're
stretched in any way bringing that stuff
to life and uh no it does doesn't yeah
and and and I think it's I think there's
like the way they work with the DP it it
feels doesn't feel like a shot like a
show like there's a lot of symmetry to
Everything Everything feels very thought
out and composed and there it a lot of
times in I wouldn't the only time I've
really said that when it wasn't focused
on Monsters was Gareth Edwards 2014
movie yeah which I think is a very I
think it's a very underrated movie
because it got a lot of back for for the
the way they chose to capture Godzilla
in the perspective and obscure him a lot
of the time and stuff so I
understand um but I think as time has
gone on it's become more appreciated
it's personally my favorite of the
movies that have come out it's it's
actually my favorite I know it's not the
one that we all really want but I I find
that the most effective one it's the
most well-rounded movie of all of them
it's definitely 2014 for me for my I I
know my rating easily 2014 Godzilla
versus kong king of the monsters Kong
Skull Island um really yeah a lot of
people prefer Kong Skull Island over uh
king of the monsters and I don't I I
prefer it's definitely the bottom for me
okay yeah my my my ranking would
probably be that it would be 2014 Kong
Godzilla versus Kong Kong's Skull Island
king of the monsters yeah I'm not a big
fan I've tried Kong Kong always starts
off like and then it just really me
every the last half I'm always like yeah
this is kind of this is really not the
fun is definitely wearing thin for me
and I just get annoyed it it can Plateau
king of the monsters is there there are
aspects of that movie that that are kind
of like aggravating to me um but but you
know there's a lot of really beautiful
Monster stuff so they might even average
out but but yeah like but but my point
that I was saying was that clth Edwards
I thought really
shot every moment of that with such
composition and and scale and and like
you're there but be I'm saying even when
there wasn't a monster thing happening
yeah exactly no exactly whereas the
other movies I sort of feel like they
Reserve that for the monster stuff to
sell it it doesn't really care about
doing that when you're in between scenes
with the hum like they're shot fine
they're always shot good but but but
it's like okay they really that that's
when they really give a and then I
would say this show matches that with
Gareth Edwards in at least in the
intention of we really care about every
shot we're doing like every even if it's
just a talking scene which which is most
of this Mo they really give a on
how to compose every frame yeah and I
really appreciate that uh especially for
a television series yeah where they that
is a very filmmaker this still feels
like filmmaker driven which is kind of
strange because normally you're like you
feel that with the writing and not so
much the directing and I kind of have an
inverse with this experience yeah I feel
like the directing is where the film
making shining and some of the writing
is where I feel a little bit pruner in
in how they're doing it yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah there there are a lot of there
are a lot of perfunctory beats across a
lot of the characterizations and stuff
like that but I but yeah the to varying
like to varying degrees of
appropriateness but yeah the the style
the mood the atmosphere is always on
point and it's like appropriately dreary
when it needs to be but then you'll have
these nice contrasts of like how
beautiful it is when they're out on the
beach um and then yeah you're out in the
ice and whatnot and just like when
you're looking up at snow but then just
like clouds and like you kind of lose
where the sky is like yeah there's a lot
of real Beauty and and things to Marvel
at and uh and yeah I appreciate so much
about how they've orchestrated this and
I and I like that they're giving us at
least these like kooky little things to
wonder about like okay Kurt Russell how
old is he and is he like AG ing slowly
is he regenerating regenerating somehow
is he is this going to be like a
Jurassic world character he's like a
secret clone or something like that
which I don't know how wacky they're
going to ultimately go with it but you
know I like having little Mysteries like
that on the on the surface to at least
ponder about and uh and and yeah going
back like I did think that was a really
nice moment where the two kids are able
to both identify the handwriting it's
like a real nice way to tie that all
together and you now we have you know mo
present and past Kaiju you know moments
we got this big ice dude with either the
couldn't quite tell if that was yeah
like some kind of like the force of the
suction is so cold that it free froze
everything in the cabin of the plane I
was sad I like that guy I liked his uh
his buddy from Korea very obviously is
going to die yeah yeah I mean and that's
what I mean by the writing there's a lot
of tropes and there's a lot of like this
is about what would happen you know in
in the writing and uh and yeah
seems like right now it's kind of always
up to the actors to elevate it and I
think about it less in the the
flashbacks cuz I think the three of them
just have more chemistry I think that's
what it is I think Kurt Russell helps
give chemistry with anybody he's
directly interacting with and the
present Trio I don't feel as much just
like natural Chemistry Between as like
when you cut to three of them in the
past they have even when the writing
could be better and even when you're
like oh I know exactly what's going to
happen the military's going to come in
they're going to be too gung-ho they're
going to lead completely ser and all
that stuff you still feel that sense of
magic at the end when they kind of
strike that deal of like all right well
you can tell me everything I need to
know you basically can do your research
and I'll act as a buffer to help you get
that done and deal with you know the
people upstairs who have clearly shown
us how they're going to handle our
research or how our our Endeavor here
and I keep think at one part of me in my
rewrite brain I'm waiting to see how the
season plays out sure before I commit to
this thought
is I don't think you need kiry Clemens I
think you could have translate
transplanted a lot of that to the sun it
would have made him more interesting if
he himself had become some type of like
hacker person and he investigates it
himself but Greg and and I I think he
has zero chemistry with kiry Clemen
there's none yeah and I and I kind of I
and they're supposed to
be you could make some weird
argument for him and the sister being
like they're distant and St he's not
allow no I
honestly it kind of feels to me like
they went we have these two leads but
she's his half sister we cannot
orchestrate a a romance here so we need
him to have an ex flame so he can have a
romance with a pretty lead who we have
sort of tacked on and I like that kind
of character that kiry Clemens is
playing I like the way she's playing it
but I I don't disagree in current form
that there's no thought put in her yeah
she's here to be character and have the
you know info when it's needed basically
she so along for the adventure and I'm
like but you are
the you you're so uninterested like yeah
and and again it's one of those things
where I'm like maybe if they they showed
us that moment in the previous episode
where kentaro comes by and she like
blows him off and then she's like I'm
working on other things but she's
clearly digitizing all the Monarch stuff
and it's like maybe just an extra beat
to show like what your obsession with
this is aside from just being annoyed
that he brought this to your door orud
yeah give it just give us like some
secret fun to unpack even if it's
just normal human Stakes by the end that
it reveals to be like give us something
with those characters to wonder about or
to think of their allegiances in
relation to me melodrama or character's
arguing does not immediately equate to
strong conflict or compelling care it
just doesn't and and it's to me it just
like it feels like perfunctory melodrama
and uh it does and the way the brother
and sister treat each other is
indicative of that because it's clear
the main beat that the two of them focus
on is just like our dad cheated and it's
kind of like the only piece of character
history that informs most of their
interactions and then with kiry Clemens
it's just like oh we used to be
together
drama and uh I yeah like it's yeah it's
just one of those things where you're
sitting there going
so boring you're just like guys I and
two I mean you never know but like
sitting here with everything as good as
it is now I'm everything else as sort of
interesting this so much of this for for
as much as we've had critique throughout
this review this show is like better and
more engaging than I was expecting like
I'm having a lot of fun watching it and
so I expected it to be slightly better
only because the Rotten Tomato score was
like through the roof on it still is
yeah it's so High yeah and and and it's
like I expected it to be see I yeah I
didn't see that until after we started
watching the first couple of episodes
and I had a primer and so if I had seen
that I might be a a bit more disappo I
was damn this just like almost at a
100 right now yeah and and so that yeah
that leads me to believe like oh it's
got all the cool pulp you want but also
probably has like some at least
affecting drama and and he's like I I
don't really care about any of the drums
like it's it is about as boilerplate as
you could get aside from it being about
a guy searching trying to get his wife
back or something you know like and so
that's I I I don't know how much to
expect out of that from the season going
forward I certainly hope that because
this is all done I assume like they're
not it's not like Network TV where
there's a period of time where like
you're shooting while stuff's airing and
you can actually adjust you know uh so I
don't know I just hope that that maybe
the writers feel emboldened upon the
back of this success in the future to
yeah write some actual like we've proven
that we can sit with some people in a
Godzilla and it's fine and now I think
it'll only help you if you get some
actual interesting those people to
do well guys uh got put work on the
video right now but what do you guys
think about this episode how are you
feeling about the Monarch series thus
far leave your thoughts down below uh be
sure to subscribe leave a like and hey
we will talk with you all soon thank you
for being
[Music]
here